欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下如何快速提升新等级
为什么我们一定要重视新等级呢
因为新等级能够决定着店铺的权重
以及能够拉升店铺流量的分配层级
让我们的店铺获得更多的免费的自然流量
接下来我们就来看看提升新等级
对我们店铺有什么样的好处
这张图是我从后台截图的
这里评定的等级就是本月的等级
那么这个预测的新级就是下个月的新等级
那么它的指标会在这边
这个是它的一个新级的各项指标的综合指标
那么提升店铺新等级对于我们有什么好处呢
第一个就是流量分配更多
新级越高
那么我们店铺起始的流量更多
比如说你是一星
店铺可能即使的流量可能是100
那么如果是你两星可能是200
那么你到三星的时候可能就到1000
所以说它的
区别还是挺大的
这是针对不同行业的情况不一样
我这里只是举个例子
也就是说其实
平台给店铺分配的流量的权益是不一样的
第二个就是
店铺的权重更高
星级越高权重越大
那么在同等条件下
你的产品的排名能够更加靠前
排名靠前了,那么你的曝光量
和点击可能就会得到更多
那么是不是能够得到更多的客户进店
来发行盘
这样的话你商机多了,订单也会随之增加
第三个就是
买家的质量更好
因为现在平台是买家跟卖家分层的
所以如果我们的层级越高
那么说明我们的实力越强平台分配客户的成绩就越高比如说你三星跟四星跟五星可能直接匹配的更多的是L2L3L4的这些买家客户这里的占比会比你一星两星的数量会大很多也就是这些客户的总量会比你一星两星的
占比更大
这些客户的质量更高
第四个就是活动流量和场景流量会更多
因为我们是
星级越高那么你有些报名活动的机会就会越多
你能够参加的活动也就更多
所以能够被系统圈品进入更多的场景获得更多的免费流量
因为平台平时圈品的时候它会有
商家等级的要求和
产品
的一个数据要求, 你只有商家符合了, 产品符合条件了, 那么才有可能被
系统, 圈品, 进入到某些
场景里面去展示产品, 这些场景基本都是免费的流量, 所以说提升星级, 是有利于获取更多的免费自然流量的
第五个就是, 直通车的推广成本更低, 同等条件下
我们店铺权重高了, 单品的权重是不是会更高
那么我们推广的时候是不是更加容易获得流量排名更加靠前排名靠前数据积累的一定的程度之后你的推广的成本是会逐渐下降
逐渐下降的所以这也是一个非常好的节省成本的一个方式就是提升我们店铺的新级
从这几个维度我们可以看出提升店铺的新等级对我们整个店铺的
指标都是非常有促进的作用的
所以说我们一定要重视
星级的提升
然后获取更多的流量
获取更多的商机
成交更多的订单
那么接下来我们来看看
它的各项具体的指标的一些
概念